how would you describe your childhood
pretty [ __ ] up
what kind of stuff was going on
all right david
david where'd you grow up where you from
originally um
ontario
california a
little town cross homes
so must and uh tell me about your family
growing up you had mom and dad
yeah i was adopted i think four months
um
never met my real parents
they
they pretty much just whatever
that
um so you were raised by foster parents
yeah yeah
i consider them my little parents my mom
i don't consider too much of anything to
me anymore what am i down here
this is your foster mom you're talking
about yeah what was what was the issue
with your foster mom she she was um
she
she never believed me she always knows
lying and [ __ ] to her
she thought i was always lying to her
and she never believed me you know
but i don't
i don't blame her i'm not like
saying it's her fault the reason why i
don't like her is
just
because uh she
she didn't i don't know i don't think
she was there good enough you know
what how would you describe your
childhood
pretty [ __ ] up
what kind of stuff was going on
a lot of sexual abuse
um
for my sisters and my brothers
like my brother used to held me down and
raped me from
and he did that for five years
and he
i heard voices ever since then
and the voice is telling me
like
that he's still looking for me
you were
the youngest
or you were
no he was about eight years older than
me his name was roger he was a bully
like big time
and um
he shot at me
with the
22
almost point blade but not
not really
about
seven feet
you know i always remember saying you're
gonna die [ __ ] and
there was only one bullet in it thank
god
you know well i wish
i would stephen i wish he would have hit
me
because it's been a struggle man like
mental [ __ ]
mental mental is real
and and my voices are real
they tell me they tell me to really
watch people you know because
ever since i've been
like a kid i had to watch out for myself
you know like my older brother raping me
and [ __ ]
and uh barbara she did too
she she was a
she was a sneaky she was sneaky because
she
when when i got charged with my
um
my mother station case i was 14 years
old when it happened
and nothing was said till i was 18 so i
didn't know i was
that's how [ __ ] up in the head it was
i didn't know that i was doing anything
wrong when i looked at it
barbara is your
uh no no not her i mean christie the the
victim that's
what i was doing well i didn't know i
was doing anything wrong
i didn't that's how i messed up the
house was you know had me thinking but
you're being molested by your siblings
yeah yeah not your mom no no no no no no
but it seems like they let it go on
because they went on too long
and went on for
it went on from
some day that that
um
seven uh
they call them the
bagwells that that's the other family
that came to the house
uh that my mom adopted and ever since
they came to the house
it just destroyed me it just destroyed
me because uh
at 15 i left i was sleeping on the
streets
getting
getting um
i mean
um
going with older older men like
62 year old man [ __ ]
you know making money because i was
hungry on the street
and it was just
it was [ __ ] terrible bro it like
really you know
that's pretty much all my life's
consistence of drugs and and sex is it
you know and i haven't had sex with a
partner since i'm 21
because
i'm
because of my my case and i just can't
have no relationship because
i just i just don't think it's going to
work so i don't even try you know so
your case when you were you were yeah i
was 14 and how old was your actually i
was 13 it was
it was happening during the eighth gr uh
after i graduated eighth grade so like
pretty much like
right before my freshman year that's
really what's happening happened for uh
for as long as i know like maybe two
weeks but but it happened you know who
is the other chrissy her name's chrissy
yeah and that was your sister yeah yeah
step sister she she was uh um
she was in blood yeah that was she yeah
uh i'm not sure i'm not even sure
she i know she's like three years
younger than me or something but
uh yeah and i and that's the biggest
mistake i mean that's why i cut myself a
lot because i think
one day i'm just gonna succeed and get
it over with
i don't care if i get shot by anybody
just
the community put me out there
in a bad way i'm not that way you know
i'm not out there i don't like kids i'm
not
i have a meditation case but it was a
juvenile case
it doesn't mean i was
with little babies i was a kid too you
know so as far as i think i think she
was like four years into me i'm not sure
but she's not too much younger than me
and i didn't think i was doing nothing
wrong you know because of you yeah it
was it was well
that
i took responsibility for that a long
time ago i do classes in y for it
but it taught me a lot like taking
responsibility for what you did it it
helps the victim a lot more
and knowing that i'm doing my part i
mean i
i'm sorry i'm out of breath but i i've
been trying to
apologize and and i just don't think
it's going to happen what would you say
to the uh i would say i would say that
was the biggest mistake and it's not
your fault that it happened it's not
your fault it's my fault i did it i take
responsibility for it
i did it so
it's not your fault when you go blaming
yourself don't blame yourself it's my
fault you did nothing wrong
and and that's why i
i slice my neck a lot i don't do it
you slice your what my neck
that's why i cook oh wow
yes
yeah you've been doing it recently too
yeah yeah and not just not to hit the
vein but just
just because
i i think i deserve
because of what happened when as a kid i
don't i i i if she goes over that yeah
yeah exactly
and
you know
it's it's [ __ ] hard for me to to know
that i did that to somebody and it's not
not you know
but
better for me i'm just gonna
i've never i'm not i haven't continued
that i haven't committed never yeah i've
never repeated it i'm never going to
it's not going to happen you were two
young kids yeah when i wa when i walk by
kids i walk over i walk away
just because
something's going on right now and
people are
acting real crazy out there
and
honest i don't see
i don't see me surviving more than
a day if i stay in l.a
but i'm not i ain't got a [ __ ] to run
for so how long have you been down here
let's get it uh i've been down here um
about
20 years about 20 years
i've been doing medicines i was 21.
that's the biggest mistake how old are
you now i'm 41. you're 41. yeah
you've been on the streets for 20 years
yeah i'm not longer than that since i
was uh 14 yeah yeah
and drugs tell me about drugs drugs um
they help me escape the um
life i i
i don't um
i have no motivation like
i do but i hear voices and they [ __ ]
with my head so bad and like it just it
gets me
it gets me bad and
and then uh i don't go for help because
i don't think
i don't think nobody's gonna help
because
all they want is a paycheck you know
have you ever tried harpy
was that therapy
yeah i had a good way of
rachel
she was my third person project 180 she
was the best she helped me through
everything
she's what i needed she i needed
something to talk to and she was there
for me you know and
and it worked so it helped you yeah it
helped me um
yeah i mean do you still have these
desires now or you avoid kids because no
i have no desires for kids but you're
just avoiding kids because you don't
want to ever i don't i just don't
i know people think of me so i'm not
gonna
put i'm gonna you know i mean i know
what people think of me so
it's not gonna change i i can't change
the way you think it's been put out
there
but i'm not that way you know i happened
once i was i was a kid myself and i'm
not making excuses but i was i was 14 i
was 14 years old i'm just trying to say
i haven't done that in my adult life
you're now a registered sex offender for
the rest of your life yeah you have to
register like every year or something
yeah
and i'm sure that affects your ability
to get a job or um no housing or no
there's people with businesses that have
mm-hmm so there are employers that yeah
oh yeah i'm a hard worker so
my my work speaks for yourself now so
you had jobs yeah what kind of jobs um i
had one it was a demolition job but i
don't we didn't do much demolition we
did a lot of yard work and um
we did a lot of yard work you know
just like cleanups
but it was hard work and i like it you
know did you finish high school uh yeah
you did and why and why
and looking at your life now
you're 41 41 41 what's your biggest
regret
what i did to my sister
by far that's the biggest mistake i've
ever done in my life if i've ever
thought of it
it's i have to think about it that's
that's off the top
have you had any relationships
as an adult
romantic relationships no no
are you lonely
no i don't i i keep myself occupied real
well like i talk to myself all day long
i i the voices that keep me going
i have i have no
time to talk to people i struggle all
day
so it's an all-day process for me to get
well and that's why walking i walk a lot
because you know i did some drugs
yesterday
and it was you know at the house i was
at the house i was at
the the drug a.a
house
um
i was doing meth more than i was out
here
so it was
i left
and
i did just a little bit more when i got
on the street but nothing more i just
wasn't smoking a lot of weed
i've done pcp acid
shrooms poppers
um
i've even drinking my own piss like with
a without knowing that i did because you
know i pissed in the bottle and i
thought it was a beer
and i drank it
on accident but nothing on purpose you
know
but uh how was that i was disgusting
that was [ __ ] gross okay
yeah
where do you stay now
i'm gonna have to work that out with my
probation i might be in violation right
now
so
uh no just just just for
not well i charged my thing so i'm still
going but just for the i guess leaving
the house because i
i don't know
no they they won't like me they meet for
that because that's not a violation i
don't have to be there it's just housing
but
i think they're pretty mad right now
yeah how do you support yourself now i
don't
uh money just get it people just give me
money and i think they do it on purpose
to see me [ __ ] up
truth to them
because uh they don't just give me five
dollars to give me two three hundred
dollars at a time
why would they give you money just
panhandling
nah uh just just just i don't know just
here like you know i would i would ask
for a secret or something to give me
money you know but
i i ain't like i used to be not like
running streets finding tricks all day
all day making money
by having sex with people yeah
yeah
and i i hate i'm not gay at all i can't
do that i mean it's it's just something
i've done
i don't know
i'm
i'm not liking it so it's out of my you
know
a couple people already gave me their
numbers and [ __ ] trying to be slick
but
i ain't with that [ __ ] i'm cool
do you feel like you were loved as a
child yeah about my dad
yeah
everybody was fake love it was fake love
like
it just i didn't feel except for my
brother michael he would he he was the
only one that
that that i had
um
feel you know like real
connection with
you know
i miss him because he's gone you know
because
he he died from drinking
you know
and uh
but
it happens you know he's he's up she's
upstairs now you know
so
what what emotions do you go through now
i go through a hurricane of emotions i
want me to i'll be happy next meeting
i'll be crying next morning i want to
kill you next minute i'll think
everybody's after me
and then uh
or something but he's plotting something
on me or
i mean it's true but
i mean i don't think i've done anything
to deserve a lot of [ __ ] that's
happening i haven't exposed myself to no
i haven't done nothing out there it's
trippy dude it's like
maybe if they snuck and see what i did
in a motel one time but
like
that was with another man he was like 30
years older than me but
i don't know who knows maybe it's the
government saying yeah what did you do
in a hotel room with him i had sex i i i
i uh he paid me
you know just for drugs
and i did all of it just for drugs it
wasn't you know
yeah
i have the word strip
you know i'm not using a lot right now
i'm using too much because
i shouldn't be using it at all but
it
um i shot up last night
because i was
i was ready
i was gonna
uh
go by on a wheelchair and a bridge and
go
you know just go [ __ ] relax just
not
under the bridge but over it just
looking over watching the freeway
you know
are you suicidal at times you think all
day long yeah
yeah
and
there ain't no reason i don't know why
it's just
i don't know why i'm like that i'm so
[ __ ] depressed all the time and it
affects my daily life if you ask people
at the program they would say man i was
i flipped out
four different times took off
and for what reason i don't know
i don't know i can't comprehend what i
why i've done you know what i have
voices have a lot to do with what that
has been going on like
my last couple
days
yeah
is your problem getting worse or has it
been it's getting
yeah because um i don't want to do
speeding one i have no somebody just
offered me something i tried i turned it
down i never turned it down
i'm too afraid to be on it because
i don't i know what it i know what
people think's you know the drug drugs
mess makes me want to be in a motel room
and watching porn all day that's all i
want to do but only if it's indoors not
anybody could see me
i just want to watch the video you know
by myself and that's it's it's it's part
of an addiction if i don't have speed
i don't have points without pointing
down it's like it's like it goes hand in
hand you know
those those two that's why it's so
addicting to me yeah
it's crazy what are you afraid of in
your life
uh
um what am i for you let me see
um
i'm afraid of death bro
i'm afraid you're a suicidal sometimes
yeah
um i know i know at the moment
i get suicidal
but
i haven't i mean i had one cut
maybe
six months ago it was this long and they
had to put glue all in it
that was about the deepest one i've done
but i'm kind of addicted
to slicing my neck because
it doesn't even hurt no more it's like
it's like a high for me it's pretty sad
you know i
i cry over because that's a [ __ ] up
thing but i i i
it's me
you know do you see how
what happened to you as a child might
have set this whole chain of events and
put you where you are
yeah yeah because being raped you see
that that wasn't your fault either
yeah i think it was my fault that was
your fault i think so that you were
molested as a child yeah because they
don't like they they had they didn't
like me anyways from the get-go you know
they
they hated me from the first day i
took a breath you know i died when i was
three and i
and i hate my sister for bringing me
back she brought me back i drowned in a
pool
and she i hate her for that i have true
hate for her
for i truly hate her for that [ __ ] she
should have never done that that was not
a reflection
that was not a business you know have
you ever been on any psych magic kit oh
yeah i'm on a lot i'm on invade good
it's a shot um
sarah quill they put me on so many damn
drugs and i'm strung out on so boxing
you ever heard of suboxone i'm just
trying to [ __ ] out on me
like i took
i took 60
pills in three days that's you don't do
that [ __ ]
and that's what i did
so i'm kind of sick over it
you know
but
i need and i'm going to get some
you know when i get it i'm going to do a
lot of them
because i'm at that point you know
so
it's like i like to [ __ ] almost go
through near-death experiences when i do
my drugs because
i don't know
it's fun to me do you have any place you
can go to for help
now with my like with the voices i've
tried
and i and nothing works but working out
i like i like working out
i love working out and
it helps me with and walking and playing
sports i like playing sports
and even talking to people
talking to people gets a lot of [ __ ] off
my chest man and i'm not the one to lie
to you i'll tell you if you ask me
questions i'm straightforward
you know
because i'm not a liar and i'm not
hiding nothing no more you know
obviously
why i say that is because when i was a
kid i was hiding the fact that what all
the sex stuff was going on in the house
was all right
but now i i reversed that it wasn't
right
it wasn't right and it's never right
you know
and
yeah and
it doesn't change the fact that
if there's a problem you got to be fixed
and i'm willing to fix it
you know
that's the thing between me and a lot of
these 290s or 290s they don't even want
to help themselves anything
it's just a it's a it's a category of
sex offenders and um
people have been charged with with sex
offenses
it it's it's it's basically the
registration
program they got
yeah i don't know i i got sentenced to
life but i think i have a chance to get
it off my record
because it was a juvenile case too
have you ever been in love as an adult
uh
no
no i have four kids and i don't love
them
because the mom
their mom
took off you know
and and now they're brainwashed so have
you ever seen your kids or spend time
with them i i could call them yeah i can
call them anytime i want but i don't
give that number out i know
i'm sure that
that's my family you know
and
yeah i love them but
they're brainwashed
you know
they haven't given me a chance because
of what them their moms said
that uh
because of the case because of the
juvenile case she she held she all that
and she
she
we we got kind of married i think it was
a marriage
it was in
vegas but it was quick and we did that
and
i forgot what the [ __ ] i was just gonna
say um yeah i didn't love her
she she she uh
she i can't say it was for money i was
broke and i was living out for money but
i don't know what it was i think it was
a trick i think somebody paid me to do
it because
i'm not like dude i'm and she if you see
her she's very beautiful and you
wouldn't think
uh you know that was a commanding line
so but
do you have any friends yeah i got a lot
of friends i think i'll probably not
know more
probably not
my best friend was jaime jaime lopez
he he was my best friend we we we lost
contact with like 21 cause that's when
my drug impact
problem got bad and i ran back to l.a
but
he he i don't know if he's a cop now i
think he might be a cop or or maybe even
richer or uh i know one of the kids are
our cop but yeah that was my best friend
yeah we played soccer baseball
everything together it was cool
yeah
where do you see your life going from
here david um
wherever god wants us to go man if it's
whether it's
whatever i'm not i'm ready for the
challenge
you know
it's god's plan i mean
you know all right yeah
thank you so much for sharing your story
all right i wish so i was like a little
shy but i mean i that's how my brain
works i wander off i actually i forget
what i'm talking about you know it's
heavy stuff you're talking about a lot
of [ __ ] going on my head all the time
and just because it doesn't go away
that's why i uh i take deep breaths
because i'm out of breath a lot because
of all the [ __ ] that's going on in my
head it's crazy
yeah and i just
yeah
i'm gonna go
i'm not doing no drugs nothing i'm i'm
drugstore i'm gonna go eat that's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna go eat i'm gonna
buy some lunch yeah